this video is sponsored by Henson
shaving clouds they're a mixed Bunch
they're all just water suspended in the
atmosphere either in liquid droplets in
low clouds or ice crystals in high
clouds but depending on a bunch of
parameters like altitude atmospheric
flow available moisture and so on they
can take on lots of different specific
forms and this year is actually the
250th birthday of Luke Howard who came
up with our International naming system
for specific types of clouds so I'm
going to use his system to rank which
ones I think are the best am I going to
do every cloud type absolutely not that
there's like over a hundred of them is
this going to be incredibly biased and
subjective absolutely to begin with we
need a reference what goes in the middle
of the board in C tier I think
cumulus mediocrus the Clue's in the name
this is a cloud
if you are someone to draw a cloud
they're going to draw you one of these
these are like Simpsons clouds they're
very common and they're
yeah they form when warm air near to the
surface Rises and doing so it expands
and cools down eventually it might cool
to a temperature called its dew point
where all the water vapor that's
dissolved in the air will condense out
and form water droplets forming a cloud
and it will look like this but your
basic Cloud so with that as our
reference let's go from the worst clouds
to the best clouds and what belongs at
the very bottom
foreign
fog okay
there's a lot more watery than I
anticipated being fog is nothing more
than water droplets suspended in the air
so it is technically a cloud it's just a
cloud that's very very close to the
surface I wouldn't even really put it on
the board but we've got to have
something left here however if the fog
forms just a little bit higher above the
ground it will form a stratus cloud the
most common example of which is
stratocumulus stratiformis it's just
such a depressing Cloud if it's an
overcast day and you look outside and
there's nothing but like a sheet of
white from one horizon to the other it's
probably a stratiformis cloud and if
you're in a plane and look down you
can't see anything just to see if clouds
that's probably also a stratiformis
cloud they're flat they're boring and
frankly they're just depressing so
they're a little bit better than fog
they're going in E2 another species of
very low Cloud forming less than two
kilometers above the surface is the
slightly more interesting Nimbostratus
these clouds are very thick they are
full of moisture they're gray they're
ugly and they produce pretty much
constant reputation rain or snowfall the
UK Met Office actually describes them as
probably the least picturesque of all
the major cloud types and I don't
disagree they're kind of ugly like the
stratiformis clouds these are depressing
but they're a bit more dramatic about it
so I'm going to put them up here into D
so far we've only considered very low
clouds let's now go up to the top part
of the troposphere and actually the low
part of the stratosphere forming at up
to 20 kilometers above the surface we
find cirrus clouds these are our first
ice clouds so instead of being formed of
water droplets they're formed of tiny
ice crystals and these clouds look thin
and wispy and very different
interestingly we actually observe them
on other planets too so Mars Jupiter
Neptune even Titan though that's not
necessarily Water Ice in those clouds
it's ices of other things like ammonia
the cool thing about cirrus clouds is
that they can show you how the
atmosphere is Flowing like sometimes
you'll see a bunch of ice crystals have
formed and then the atmosphere has
carried them in and trained them along
one of the nicknames for cirrus clouds
is mares Tales because they look like a
horse's tail they're very high clouds
full of ice crystals show you how the
atmosphere is flowing
but I think they're pretty ugly
personally I don't think I could put
them any higher than D2 next up however
are the slightly more interesting
serostratus clouds you've probably
noticed some repeated names here that's
from Howard's systems so Ciro or cirrus
clouds refer to them being high up
Stratus refers to them being flat and
cumulo refers to them being kind of
fluffy like a cauliflower so this is a
thin flat sheet of ice crystals which
should be pretty boring but what brings
it up to seed here is the fact that it
produces some really interesting Optical
phenomena like Halos and Sun dogs caused
by sunlight reflecting off the ice
crystals in the layer so that makes it a
bit more interesting I'm happy to put
this in C tier so we've now caught up
with our reference level all the clouds
from this point onwards are more
interesting than your basic cumulus
cloud we're actually going to start with
another type of cumulus cloud the
stratocumulus flockus so as the name
suggests this is a combination of a flat
stratus cloud and a fluffy cumulus cloud
but more interesting I think than either
the Flocka species in particular I think
is interesting because it for forms
where the atmosphere is unstable there's
lots of turbulent motion what that does
is it breaks apart a sheet Cloud into
lots of little fluffy cumulus clouds
that are all still Loosely together it's
your basic Cloud then but just a bit
more chaotic so I think that puts it in
beat here going up into the medium level
clouds another more interesting cumulus
cloud is an alto cumulus the alto
meaning medium level so a more
interesting cumulus cloud but with
interesting subspecies like autocumulus
angelatus which show off oscillatory
Behavior which is like making the
physics of the atmosphere visible so
that's cool I think solidly in B tier
and then lastly in B tier mamatus clouds
Yep they're named after memories these
are these are boob clouds these form
when turbulence in a larger cloud like a
cumulonimbus will cause this ocillatory
undulating behavior in the underside and
it forms these really interesting
patterns especially when illuminated at
Sunset they look interesting they've got
a funny name
B for boob clouds and now something
that's going to be controversial for a
lot of people not to loosen clouds this
is the highest type of cloud in the
atmosphere they're made of tiny amounts
of ice crystals that are in the
mesosphere actually near the Misa pores
so like 80 85 kilometers above the
surface only over the poles and they're
only visible in Twilight after the sun
has set the sun's rays will still
illuminate the ice crystals and be
scattered down to the surface and they
produce these gorgeous patterns like I
think these are the most beautiful kind
of clouds that would put them in s tier
but unfortunately they are in the
mesosphere and as everyone knows the
mesosphere is the worst most boring part
of the atmosphere so they're gonna go
down a tier in a now let's bring things
back much much closer to the surface in
fact the next species of cloud is only
formed because of how close to the
surface they are lenticular clouds when
air is flowing over the surface and is
displaced by terrain like around a
mountain it produces turbulence and and
if moisture Laden air then runs into
that turbulence and if the temperature
is below the dew point a lenticular
cloud can form around that area of
turbulence because these clouds are
fixed in place by the terrain feature
and the resulting turbulence they look
kind of unlike any other species of
cloud in fact they look a lot like
flying sources and have been suggested
as explanations for historical UFO
sightings very cool A2 and now dear
audience we are left with the creme de
La Creme the S tier clouds and perhaps
not a surprise that the first entry
cumulonimbus these things are the
granddaddies of clouds they are
atmospheric physics writ large they're
vast they're dense they produce
precipitation and thunderstorms and they
stretch the entire depth of the
troposphere they form when really
powerful updrafts bring tons of moisture
up through the atmospheric column
stretching right the way to the top of
the troposphere and when that air
reaches the top of the troposphere and
it collides with the stratosphere it
can't propagate upwards anymore the
stratosphere doesn't allow vertical
movement so that moisture then spreads
outwards and it forms the top of what
some people call an anvil cloud the
result is a vast cloud with a
well-defined top and the bottom in fact
it really clearly marks out the boundary
of the troposphere which is just awesome
so they could only really go in s tier
and the other two entries in s tier are
actually connected to cumulonimbus in
one form or another first of all Arcus
clouds these are formed by the
interaction of the strong updraft in the
cumulonimbus cloud with a sending air
mass or a downdraft and if there's a
wind shear so two different horizontal
winds at two different levels then that
interaction can cause the air to spin
and be spat out in front of the
cumulonimbus cloud and these Arcus or in
this case shelf clouds look amazing like
to me they look a lot like the alien
spaceship in Independence Day entering
the atmosphere one of the most epic
kinds of clouds sometimes though these
clouds can detach entirely from the
cumulonimbus and form a roll cloud and
that's an example of an atmospheric
soliton it's a wave with a single Crest
that propagates through the atmosphere
without changing its shape or its speed
it's just a rotating cylinder of
moisture propagating through the
atmosphere epic s tier and lastly we've
previously learned that clouds are
formed when air rises and the air rises
because it's warm warm because the
ground or the sea underneath is warm
but that isn't the only cause for
updrafts over wildfires and volcanic
eruptions we also see updrafts and
sometimes those updrafts cause clouds to
condense and we call those clouds
pyrocumulus in fact sometimes the
updraft from wildfires and volcanoes is
so intense that it actually forms a
cumulonimbus cloud in which case we call
it a cumulonimbus flammogenitus
oh God great great name and these clouds
are no joke they are violent I mean they
look violent but also in terms of what
they do so sometimes a pyrocumulus cloud
will precipitate out and it will help
put out the fire that caused it but more
often than not these clouds produce
strong low-level winds that whip up the
fire even more and make it more
dangerous these things are rare rad and
violent
top of the list S2 and there we go this
is my official ranking of all the best
kinds of clouds did I miss your favorite
or do you just disagree with me let me
know in the comments but before you do
that I actually have another bonus
ranking for you some YouTubers have got
some great beards for example Rohan
Francis Tom Clark excellent beards but
down here at the bottom a bit of a gap
except there's not a gap
that's where I go I didn't shave during
the last year of my PhD until I
submitted my thesis and the resulting
thesis beard was
awful what's keeping this monstrosity
away from the public that's right it's
this video sponsor Henson shaving did
you know that over 2 billion disposable
razors enter landfill in the us alone
every single year all over the world
people want to or need to shave but
doing so we don't have to create lots of
waste enter Henson shaving instead of
stacking lots of Steel blades on top of
each other and then surrounding it in
plastic only to be thrown away Henson
produces the al-13 this thing is
entirely plastic free as is its
packaging and it's designed to last a
lifetime instead of using disposable
heads it takes a single really sharp
razor blade that you then change out
every five uses or so the result is less
waste fewer emissions and a really nice
shave Henson actually used to make parts
for the International Space Station so
this thing is so precise and so well
engineered specifically to keep the
blade as still as possible which means
that it vibrates less and you get a
closer shave not an exaggeration to say
that when I first used it I spent the
rest of the day just touching my face
because it was so smooth head on down to
the description and click the link and
if you use the offer code Simon then
you'll get a hundred free blades with
your purchase of eraser and that's
enough to last you for two years I'm
really impressed by them and I'm going
to keep using the Razer and I think you
should check it out too thank you very
much to Henson for sponsoring this video
thank you so much for watching the video
If you like this topic it was actually
picked by my patrons so every month I
try to give my patrons a poll where they
can choose a video topic for the
upcoming month I think the next one is
actually active when this video comes
out so if you'd like to pick a video
then do consider becoming a patron you
get a bunch of other benefits you get
early access to videos and access to a
behind the scenes Vlog every month if
you did enjoy the video please do pop it
a like and if you'd like to watch more
stuff from me then here's some
recommended viewing next that just leads
me to say thank you once again for
watching I'll see you in the next one